[Music]
all right joining us now with more on
tonight's breaking news he is the host
of CR TV's Levin TV the host of life
liberty Levin right here Sunday night
the number one show on its timeslot on
the Fox News Channel we call him the
great one Mark Levin mark let's start
with the president and the hysteria that
came out last week and the so-called
experts have been so wrong the entire
time well the president's actually in
great shape when it comes to the law and
when it comes to impeachment on
impeachment all we have to do is vote
and make sure the Democrats don't win
and then he won't be impeached there's
an idea anyway that's the headline
though the president is in very good
shape
you cannot impeach a president on events
that occurred before it was president I
don't know if people are aware of this
the precedent is Vice President Collier
case in 1873 judges different presidents
vice presidents on events that occurred
beforehand so even if they load up their
phony list we know what we ought to keep
that in mind also they're serious doubt
on whether mr. Muller in his report can
use grand jury information that goes
public
remember grand juries are secret grand
jury information is supposed to be
secret there's a big case going on now
in Washington DC relating to this
Congress passed a statute to keep this
information secret because when an
individual is in front of a grand jury
they don't have a lawyer the other side
can't be told there's no counter to what
the government is doing so they're gonna
have a big hurdle I think to get over it
to even allow the information that's in
front of a grand jury to get to the
American people by way of mr. Rosenstein
because that is a miscarriage of justice
what else
obstruction of justice I'm going through
what they've been arguing president
cannot obstruct justice for firing a
subordinate period now what about this
new thing they've come up conspiracy to
defraud an election well I'd like to
know this conspiracy exactly who did the
president conspire with who is it have
they been charged had they been
prosecuted who did the president
conspire with he didn't conspire with
anybody because there is no such thing
and of course the big enchilada which is
a sitting president cannot be indicted
which I've been saying for 18 months
which
makes all of this entirely bogus now
let's move to the Southern District in
New York they're pursuing campaign
violations that did not occur while I
agree with aspects of what professor
Dershowitz said I disagree with this
these are not crimes period intent who
paid whom doesn't matter these are
events that are not defined as campaign
violations but I would ask the geniuses
in the Southern District of New York
which candidates have you or any other
US attorney prosecuted for violating
these laws when they used private funds
or corporate funds to settle a private
legal matter can you give me one can you
name one two three four if this is the
law I assume you've used it on a whole
bunch of other people well where's the
case law because I don't see that now
the one area that bugs me is the New
York Attorney General who's a hack and
the DA in Manhattan who's another hack
these are elected Democrats so they can
look at these areas to the federal
immunity on indictment doesn't
necessarily apply to them if I were the
president I'd look across the United
States and I would hire the five or six
toughest smartest most aggressive
litigators in the country I'd pull them
together around my table and I would say
I want you to do everything you can to
go in the offensive against these
political prosecutors I don't care if
you have to drag out their cases I don't
care how many motions you have to file
it's time to go on offense against these
political phony prosecutors in the state
of New York and in Manhattan now if you
don't mind Sean I'd like to briefly talk
about this Bruce or because I think he
is very very keen questions you're doing
great but on your own well thank you I
view this guy Bruce Laura's kind of a
mole to be perfectly honest with you
he's on the staff of the Deputy Attorney
General of the United States first Sally
Yates and then Rod Rosenstein there's a
ton of questions this man needs to be
asked because he seems to be the center
of the wheel and that is what role all
roles did he play in the production of
this dossier his relationship
with fusion GPS with where his wife
worked his relationship with Christopher
Steele the full extent of it is what we
need to know because he clearly was a
back-channel for opposition research
there in the United States Department of
Justice I want people to remember the
FBI directors gone he is a leaker he was
fired
the deputy FBI director is gone he's
under criminal investigation the mr.
stroke who was head of
counterintelligence investigations he
was fired have you ever seen anything
like this before
now in the Deputy Attorney General's
Office you have a guy who is colluding
with a former British spy a foreigner to
affect our election whose wife just
happens to be working for the opposition
research outfit funded by Hillary
Clinton and the DNC stick with me
because it's very simple and they're the
ones that colluded with Russia so the
question is not only what was his role
who did he communicate with at the FBI
who did he communicate with the
Department of Justice what did he tell
Sally Yates what did he tell rod
Rosenstein did he talk to Brennan did he
talk to clapper
did he talk to the White House every
single person he talked what media
outlets did he potentially speak to we
need to know that too this is all very
very important and any members of
Congress did he talk to did he talk to
Reid did he talked to Adam Schiff list
and he talked to any of these people and
who provided what information to whom on
this dossier was he behind the scenes
prodding along to make sure the
application was written the way they
wanted it to write to go to the vice of
court what we're also going to be
watching tomorrow is the Democrat Party
the Democrat Party is the obstruction
party almost anarchist they do not care
if the Department of Justice was lawless
they do not care that the senior level
the FBI wiped itself out they've been
defending them they've been special
leaders for lawlessness that's the
question all right great one Mark Levin
thank you